there's a story man Andrew Tate has lung
cancer
what leaked medical documents reveal now
they're saying does he and the report
people are saying is that he does
they say he has lung cancer he may have
lung cancer according to a letter
written by his doctor in in Dubai
the letter from Tate's general
practitioner at King's College Hospital
in United Arab Emirates suggests CB
repatriated to the gulf Nation
immediately the letter had medical
reports in English appear to be
translated into Romanian Tate is
currently in custody in Bucharest on
allegations of rape and trafficking hold
on there a minute he's never been
charged with any crime which is the
creepiest and weirdest thing about the
they're like when we when we suspect you
of a crime we lock you up for six months
who is the information coming from that
he's his doctor his doctor yeah but it's
leaked you said right yeah and it says
he may have lung cancer yeah there was a
scan that found a spot on his lung and
they needed to get him in because they
think he has lung cancer uh I just want
to be careful here because I know
there's a lot of misinformation
um from both sides of fans and uh
detractors of Tate he is currently 36 I
know he smokes cigars but people getting
lung cancer in people younger than 45 is
extremely rare he's in very good shape
although he does smoke uh it it would be
very rare for him sure and you know what
maybe it's fake news but uh he's not
been charged with any crime so he should
not be in custody until they charge him
with a crime yeah do the right thing
guys release him because this is staying
on Romania for a century I already you
know I was talking before about how I
loved brajav and Bucharest and they were
great places and I'm not sure I want to
go to go back to a place like this it's
disgusting look man you can criticize
agitate for a whole lot of things and
don't look at me I don't know but to
detain a guy for six months without
charge or trial like if he's actually
the villain you think he's it's going to
show itself you don't need to but he's
got to do it when these women came out
and said like Hey we're not victims
they're lying the judge goes nah you're
brainwashed like what dude if a witness
statement isn't good enough and you're
claiming the witness testifying on his
behalf is brainwashed
there's no justice system I'm not
particularly sympathetic to Tate's
stories like I I think that he might
have broken Romania law I think it's
probably it's actually likely that he
broke Romanian law in the whole uh the
what is it the the sweet boy or whatever
Loverboy lover boy thing uh charge him
with a crime yeah exactly 100 that's
that's exactly where I was going even if
you know even if he did if he did do
something or if they suspect him charge
him so that way it's above board and and
allow the Romanian justice system to
take you know take its course but charge
him just holding him you know let him go
yeah or let him go that's fine too I
think um a part of this story is that um
Andrew Tate is becoming less and less
relevant as he's being held longer and
longer in jail because he's unable to
produce content and as that progresses
his relevancy decreases I think this
might just be a stunt to try to keep his
name in the media and the news and to
elevate the story more to try to help
him get out it did it concerned me that
this is a desperate attempt to get him
out of prison it's attention because
it's diminishing because he can't make
content unless people are covering it I
don't care if there is a 0.001 chance
this is true
he should not be held without charge and
so it doesn't matter if they need to or
don't
this is all the more reason like think
about how insane this is if you're
suggesting the story is fake that would
mean that Tate's team is like okay he's
being charged with that he's being he's
been held in custody without charges
what scheme can we come up with to get
him released it's like holy crap he
shouldn't be in any custody at all
without charges I shouldn't need to do
this definitely he should not be in
custody in Hell being held without you
so why would they so so the idea I'll
put it this way if they are faking this
story to try and get him out of jail
good for them
okay if the end's justify that means
yeah the American Revolutionary of you
but but what you're the answer to by the
means in that the bad guy in this story
is Romania not the people trying to free
the guy who's being unjustly held I
agree that he is being unjustly held but
just specifically on the story here of
him having lung cancer right so you know
that's what I'm talking about if a woman
is kidnapped is it like I don't know if
we should use violence against this guy
because the ends don't justify the means
like no no no no no no the bad guy is
the person who kidnapped the person not
the person trying to figure out a way if
there's a guy who's holding someone kept
him in his basement and we're like the
only way to free this person is to sneak
in in the middle of the night break the
window unlock the oh that's breaking and
entering dude the ends don't justify the
means this is different if they have
dirt on him they need to bring the
charges and he needs to be brought in
Forth with the judge and they need to
show that evidence I think in Romania
I'm not completely familiar with their
legal system but they have X amount of
time to hold him while they look for the
evidence which is weird and
um I just think they do it differently
in Romania too which doesn't make it
right yeah that apparently is extension
it was the attention was extended 30
days three days ago they said last week
they just extended it so like he doesn't
even know when they're going to release
him they're just like this lesion on his
lung by the way is from March of 2022.
um he got a health screening back then
and he was reassured at the time that
the mass was likely benign but is
advised to get further tests this could
be like the uh Joe Biden you know benign
skin cancer yeah we absolutely he should
have more tests I I just think look man
if Andrew Tate is innocent of these
accusations they shouldn't be holding
him and if he is guilty
and these charges these accusations are
correct they are losing the prosecution
against him by doing this they're making
themselves look evil and making him look
like the victim every day they're
holding him so all the only outcome in
this for Romania is net negative the
only logical solution is to release the
guy they shouldn't have locked him up if
they didn't have the goods to begin with
they shouldn't have locked him up and it
shouldn't be like oh we're locking him
up to find the goods now I don't know I
don't if that is that the the way the
legal system works in Romania when
you're accused of a crime they will
detain you and put bring it and lock you
up and then start looking for evidence
that's insane I uh
Jessica was bad I don't live in Romania
I don't agree with their way of doing
things I think it is we in America we
have the right to a speedy trial we have
a right to a jury of our peers we have a
right to confront our accusers
and in Romania they're doing none of
that they're just like not like them up
extended period of time yeah that's
wrong and they're losing on it because
on the world stage as much as the
corporate press and their weirdo
cultists are going to be like
undertake's bad sure but they they're
not going to get someone like me and I'm
and I'm I'm ready to be like well he's
got a bunch of really awful videos maybe
these stories are true I don't care if
the stories are true at this point if
you have not charged them and you don't
have the goods to charge him detaining
him makes you look like the villain
innocent until proven guilty could he be
extradited by the US government I think
they're doing this in Romania they're
not like trying to bring him here on
things I think they're trying to charge
him could the US government be like we
demand you release him back to the
United States he's a U.S citizen uh is
he a U.S citizen I think he is assuming
that he is could could the government
like they're holding an american guy in
uh against like in a detention that's
unconstitutional the United States the
U.S doesn't the U.S won't do that
they'll they'll allow the country to go
through their uh their justice system a
friend of mine Randy was uh held in
um where is it the Czech Republic uh on
trumped up murder charges
um because some kid jumped up on stage
and and he pushed him off and wait who
did Randy Blythe from Lamb of God he
wrote a book about it it was six seven
years ago he was uh held in um in the
Czech Republic
um it might even be longer than six
seven years ago but he uh he had to deal
with all their with all their guys their
issues holy what's that the daily
wire sold 100
000 chocolate bars as of 8 47 p.m
just during the episode or all time in
12 hours 12 hours they sold 100
000 bars of chocolate wow damn are they
selling them by individual bars we need
to get on this game yeah dude tap in man
Jeremy got all the connections they must
have made a couple million bucks already
we're a hair care product man 100 000
bars Men's Hair Care yeah let's roll I
mean I'll do it with 100
000 bars yeah but how much are they
selling them for
let me check
wait what oh
I'm getting some weird security
restriction
I think we need to get in the beanie
game before we get into the hair product
game we're working on it a four pack is
25 bucks
all right so we're talking about like
what 25 it's like six bucks a bar yeah
well then that's before taxes I imagine
six dollars per bar all right I don't
care what anyone says Jeremy won the
club the culture War is Over Jeremy
boring won the culture War how much is
the daily wire because between Noel's
book with no words in it and Jeremy's
razors and the uh the chocolate bar if
you buy a 24 pack it's 100 bucks right
so that's what a bit cheaper a little
bit more than four bucks how much is
that Mr Beast bar
oh yeah yeah that's called uh feastables
right feastables feastables is pretty
popular he wrote daily wires is breaking
the cycle of lose and boycott and
is instead creating actual Alternatives
feastables Jimmy where's your favicon I
still get the global icon you need a
cool favicon man
favicon yeah
man we got our our coffee coming soon
but uh I'm you know we're we're sitting
here trying to get this thing launched
since December and then the company that
we we work with is like it'll be done in
seven days and then they come back to us
after we sign and they're like six weeks
and we're like what
whatever it still is one of the best
companies we've found in terms of the
the product the freshness the delivery
the all the things they can do
and so we're like how did Jeremy do this
in 12 hours or not even in 12 hours in
like six hours like we're trying to get
when you got it you got it he's on
Sentry Duty right now if he sees a
company like just obliterate their
product with wokeness he's like call
them make them make the call Jeremy this
better be some good chocolate
you know give me the nuts thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time